the holiday season for many is a time of
Celebration generosity and tradition for
some there is a mascot who effortlessly
exemplifies all of these qualities and
his name is the Hebrew hammer and he's
awesome look at that thanks Hammer but
for others there is Santa Claus a jolly
fat man who employs slave labor and
breaks into people's houses in the
middle of the night but those who are
uninitiated may be surprised to learn
that Santa is actually the good version
many pop culture icons have another side
to them a shadow a Yang to their Yang
Superman has Bizarro Spider-Man has
venom link has Dark Link even arach has
an evil twin named Brent Rivera but in
the case of Old St Nick his shadow is
not an opponent but sort of an ally if
you want to hear how the ancient entity
known as Kampus tortured a generation of
naughty kids and how one family in 2015
reawakened him like never before stick
around to the end of this
[Music]
video
welcome to Ho Ho Horror history I can
truly never forgive myself for that joke
earlier this year I made a Horror
history episode on Sam the Halloween
mascot from director Michael dh's 2007
horror Anthology trick-or treat where I
also mentioned another holiday tradition
horror film that dhy had directed his
2015 film
[Music]
Kus
St in the first video I talked about how
Sam's role was to preserve ancient
holiday traditions punishing those who
break the holiday rule so Kampus in a
way is a spiritual successor but instead
of enforcing traditions of Celtic
folklore Kampus hails from ancient
Alpine and Nordic Legends typically
depicted as a horned goat demon hybrid
kumus is sometimes covered in black fur
while at other times taking a more human
appearance he's often seen covered in
Chains and sporting a bundle of birch
branches which are used to imprison and
SWAT misbehaving children he can
sometimes be seen with a bundle or sack
much like Santa Claus himself but
instead of using it to distribute toys
it's usually filled with bad kids so he
can transport them to Hell capturing
children in inside of his sack is one of
the many parallels he shares with Sam
but to understand kmus and to stay off
his naughty list I'm going to go over
his entire history so let's take it back
to the earliest winter
[Music]
celebrations while the date of krampus's
origin has seemingly been lost to time
the holiday traditions that he
represents ironically traced back even
before Christmas and kmus only became
associated with the holiday once it
became widespread it's believed that the
Romans were one of the biggest
celebrators of the winter Soul STI the
longest night of the year in the
northern hemisphere the most popular
holiday on the ancient Roman Calendar
was saturnalia a celebration of Saturn
the god of agriculture in time as with
many ancient traditions this was all
about farming rituals people would offer
gifts to the Gods in hopes that it would
bless their winter sewing season which
is basically just when it was time to
get the seeds in the cold ground as
described in the song sewing season by
bran nit I'd have to give up my emo card
if I didn't mention that saturnalia
started as just one day but then they
just said screw it let's just make it a
whole week so it lasted from December
17th to December 25th it's a lot like
how Christmas in America lasts several
months before the actual day which is
super annoying so that may potentially
be the origin of December giftgiving
tradition saturnalia was also a time to
let loose with food and drinks just like
every holiday and businesses and schools
were closed so that everyone could
participate and I do mean everyone it
was seen as a time that all social
classes could come together and
celebrate even slaves were given
temporary Freedom during this time it
seems that this tradition is kind of
reflected in kmus which features the mom
Sarah angle and her family coming
together to celebrate Christmas with her
less well-off sister's family they got
wor Stu and how come rich people get all
the free part of the saturnalia
tradition was the celebration of the God
Mithra which fell on December 25th there
are people I'm not going to say who but
they are out there who believe that when
the Roman Catholic Church selected the
dates December 25th for Christmas their
goal was to replace the Pagan prech
Christianity rituals the Christians are
vehemently opposed to this theory if you
ask the Christian Scholars how often
they think about the Roman Empire
they'll get nervous and say I don't know
what you're talking about but it's true
that Jesus's actual date of birth is
unknown they will admit that much
Christmas is just the day that they
celebrate it but enough with all of this
Roman craft kmus is clearly a German
name so let's get to that part Kampus is
indeed German most likely named after
the German word kampen which means claw
this name is fitting for the character
because kmus is often described as a
frightening horned creature with sharp
claws reflecting its menacing and
beastly appearance I saw some sources
like Encyclopedia Britannica claiming
that crompus is the son of Hell the
underworld goddis from Norse mythology
however there's no mention of crompus in
Norse mythology it's much more likely
that he comes from Al folklore
especially considering the German name
and Austrian Traditions that were
connected to crompus crompus is said to
be a counterpart to St Nicholas who was
born in the year 270 CE so it's likely
that lorewise kmus would come into
existence around that time while St
Nicholas was a Christian Bishop known
for his kindness and generosity towards
children crompus was the opposite
punishing children who misbehaved
throughout the year St Nicholas's
followers began to celebrate a feast day
in his honor on December 6th during
which gift giving became a tradition so
kmus not to be outdone got his own
holiday on December 5th the eve of St
Nick Feast this would be known as
crompus knot or simply crompus night
Legend says that both St Nicholas and
kmus would arrive in the evening on
December 5th with St Nicholas rewarding
the good kids with presents and clompus
punishing the bad ones with chains and
his Birch branches even collecting the
worst of them to drag them to Hell which
is a way better Behavior motivator than
simply the threat of getting coal in
your stocking if any of you have kids or
even younger siblings I think it's time
to start telling them about clompus cuz
this generation is getting kind of out
of control hey watch
it oh but the next compus not tradition
that would emerge would scare even the
bravest of kids and would become an
instant
[Music]
Classic this is Kampus LA or Kampus run
a traditional parade started in Austria
where the adults dress up in realist to
kmus costumes and run through the
streets trying to scare the children
into behaving ahead of the arrival of
kmus and St Nick according to
history.com Austrian men would get drunk
and run through the streets dressed as
the Fearsome creature this account from
travel dudes.com mentions 400 gruesome
creatures whipping the legs of children
and stealing hats in freezing cold
temperatures some celebrations also
feature women dressing up as perta
another mythological being in Alpine
folklore a goddess who was associated
with the winter solstice just like
Kampus at first I thought this was just
the witch from Snow White which I guess
is actually appropriate Pera can appear
as either a beautiful goddess who
appears as white as snow or an ugly
Haggard old woman a lot like the evil
queen from Snow White Pera would team up
with kmus many years later so I'll go
deeper into her lore in a little bit
kmus L became a long-standing tradition
primarily in Austria and Germany which
has come back in a major way over the
last decade my first thought was this is
awesome why don't we have this in the
west but after doing a little digging
there are some recent kmus parades in US
cities however much like our music
festivals they are way Tamer than their
European counterparts one might even say
that they are
they meanwhile in Austria you've got
stuff like this going on I got attacked
and pulled down and so did a lot of
other people they're attacking kids
they're attacking the elderly no one was
really safe and isn't that what
Christmas is really all about but the
survival of these celebrations was not
without push back the Catholic Church
attempted to ban any celebration of Kus
in the 1100s due to the creatures
resemblance to their concept of the
devil which clearly demonstrates that
they believed in him and feared him
enough to want to bring down the
banhammer and that's pretty great over
time the celebration of St Nicholas
feast day became intertwined with
Christmas celebrations especially in
European countries and since kmus is the
dark counterpart to St Nick it to became
associated with the birthday party of
the world's most famous zombie much to
the annoyance of the Catholic Church who
was unable to stomp out the legend with
their bands maybe the Strand effect the
phenomenon of attempted censorship of a
topic inadvertently increasing awareness
about that subject should actually be
called the Kampus effect the character
managed to survive until the 1890s where
a new holiday tradition took place
Kampus carton literally just translates
to Krampus cards these holiday cards
show the December demon in a series of
snapshots where he is kidnapping various
children and it allowed word of his
power to spread around the world like
never before using the Postal Service
this is another interesting perhaps
coincidental parallel that kampu shares
with Sam Sam's Legend was spread early
on thanks to a series of Halloween
greeting cards created by Michael DH so
make sure to send your family and
friends a kmus cart in this holiday
season but I guess the increased
awareness about kumus was not enough to
deter bad behavior in one Village in
Austria during the 1930s this was in the
middle of a Great Depression for the
country and food was hard to come by a
little girl standing in a bread line was
rushed by a crowd of desperate hungry
people who stole her bread and shoved
her to the ground when she arrived home
her parents were angry at her for coming
up empty-handed and when she tried to
show some optimism by presenting her
Santa Claus doll her parents ripped it
in half causing her to lose her true
Christmas spirit and Chuck the toy into
the fireplace they to had given up and
eventually so did I and for the first
time I didn't wish for a miracle I
wished for them to go away a wish I
would come to regret and that night in
the darkness of a howling blizzard I got
my wish there's a reason I've been
pointing out all of kuso's similarities
to Sam throughout this video and that's
because by the time of Mike dh's take on
kmus in the 2015 film krampus's role in
the story has been expanded not just to
punish naughty children but to punish
anyone who has lost sight of the true
Spirit of the holiday in that sense he
becomes a lot more like Sam but for
Christmas instead of Halloween although
there is no rule that says Sam can't
come out around Christmas time and he
does maybe Sam versus crra is somewhere
in our future narratively for Kus this
could be seen as him getting stricter
with his rules over time at first he
gets people's attention by kidnapping
naughty kids but then he expands out to
include adults and anyone who
disrespects the rules of the holiday so
those who failed to uphold the tenants
of Celebration generosity and tradition
and become victims to put this in Death
Note terms it kind of follows the
pattern of how K started out by only
killing criminals but eventually
expanded to include those who did things
that are not crimes but could also hurt
others we can also see how kmus has
evolved with the times in order to
continue mirroring his lighter half St
Nicholas Old St Nick had undergone some
changes in the late modern period Dutch
settlers brought the celebration of St
Nicholas to America calling him C Claus
which was eventually Americanized to
Santa Claus it seems that his waistline
was also Americanized as he got more
popular he Enlisted the help of some
Elves to accelerate the toy making
process these would be known as Santa's
little helpers so Kampus got some
minions of his own but true to his
nature 's helpers were demonic looking
versions of symbols and objects
typically associated with Christmas
cheer they included a trio of
mischievous gingerbread man lumpy dumpy
and clumpy as well as an army of Evil
toys such as the Monstrous and Hungry
Jack in the Box known as Dirk clown a
bloodthirsty teddy bear known as Teddy
CLA and a rogue robot toy known as Tik
Tock unlike my m3gan Horror history
episode this is not some kind of
allegory about how the app Tik Tok is
corrupting the minds of the youth
because Tik Tok didn't even exist yet
there's also an evil angel puppet named
perta who seems to be another form of
the Christmas witch fral perta seen
during the kmus LA runs fra Pera would
come around after Christmas time each
year to punish those who neglect their
household duties primarily women who
didn't get all their flax spinning done
she would come to your house and set
fire to the half spun fibers if your
house was messy when she arrived or you
didn't leave out a traditional bowl of
porridge for her she was said to Slit
your stomach open with a long knife
hidden under her robes disembowel you in
your sleep and replace your guts with
rocks and straw now you understand why
people dress up as her to try to scare
kids during the kroo L run this chick is
one bad witch I was going to say
something else in addition to all of
those layers clownus also worked with a
team of troll-like creatures called uads
which each played a role in terrorizing
krampus's
[Music]
victims the uads originated from
Icelandic Christmas folklore Mountain
dwelling monsters who came down into
town around Christmas to eat disobedient
children traditionally each of them is
associated with a different prank with
varying levels of severity they include
Kat kroer the meat hook because he was
known for snatching human Meats verse
Laker the spoon Laker Hera skler the
door Slammer who gets a joy out of
making people grumpy KET sneaker the
candle beggar who eats candles leaving
his victims in the dark gotta thever the
doorway sniffer who can smell baked
goods and steals bread and cookies bukin
AER the sausage swiper who steals smoked
meat Giller the gly who puts a potato in
your shoe which is a very minor
inconvenience compared to the meat hook
guy glug the window peeper who's essenti
crompus his spy and stest the Sheep
harasser who steals sheep's milk and
also leaves a potato which could be a
good thing if you like potatoes more
than you like milk however while working
under kumus the uads take on much darker
intentions he and his
helpers I could only listen as they
dragged my family into the underworld
knowing that I would be next but Krampus
didn't take me set night he left me as a
reminder of what happens when hope is
lost when believe is forgotten and the
Christmas spirit dies the little girl is
given a bell with campus's name on it to
remember what happened that night many
decades later in the 2010s that girl has
a family of her own including her son
Tom her daughter-in-law Sarah and two
grandkids Max and Beth who refer to her
as Omi the German word for grandmother
after so many years Omi thought she was
in the clear but this year maybe the
first year that Max is old enough to
Grapple with the idea of Santa Claus
possibly being a fallacy the family's
Christmas spirit is at an all-time low
Max gets into a fight at a nativity
recital at the local Macho Mart while
his sister laughs and Records him this
is the bad behavior that catches
krampus's eye but the evil exus entity
would take notice of the entire family
when Max's letter to Santa is exposed by
the visiting cousin I just wanted
Christmas to be like it used to be but
forget it I hate Christmas I hate all of
you which is actually still not as bad
as what Kevin McAllister told his family
in home alone I don't want want to see
you again for the rest of my whole life
I hope I never see any jerks again maybe
if Kampus had been the one to break into
his house he would have had more success
than the duo of bumbling burglars anyway
Max tears up his letter to Santa and
it's sucked into a whirlwind it's almost
as if releasing this letter into the
night's air is a catalyst for the
blizzard that immediately rolls in
knocks out the power and Deadlocks the
family in place together in their own
neighborhood the next morning December
23rd Max notices a creepy snowman in the
front lawn almost spying on them and
they receive a couple of unmarked
Christmas presents at their doorstep the
neighborhood seems like it's almost
entirely empty as Beth walks down the
block to visit her boyfriend but on the
way there the sky goes dark and she
hears slay Bells over head but this is
not the Christmas legend that she is
familiar
with oh my
God Beth tries to escape to a parcel
delivery van but finds the driver frozen
to death inside so she hides out
underneath it we pretty much know what
all the family members did to provoke
krampus's wrath but what did this
delivery driver do he seemed innocent
enough like he even braved the awful
weather to deliver their package most
delivery drivers would have just dumped
it in the sewer and marked it as
delivered too much work let's burn it
and say we dumped it in the sewer
whatever happened to respect for
essential workers in any event Beth
seems to be in the clear until she
notices that Kampus has left behind a
little
present back at the house another
ominous snowman has appeared and that
evening Tom and Uncle Howard discover
hooved Footprints while out looking for
bath Howard is attacked by a creature
burrowing under the snow and nearly
pulled into the ground right then and
there presumably to take him to Hell Tom
is able to save him but the bite wounds
are severe fans tend to refer to this
creature as the snow beast it's hard to
tell exactly what it is because it's
never seen but it seems to operate
similar to the graboid from the Tremors
franchise that night as the family
drifts off to sleep around the fireplace
their only source of warmth the flame
dwindles down allowing one of the
gingerbread men to descend to the
chimney on a metal chain and abduct
Howard's son how Jun junor this happens
right after the battery dies on an iPad
that had been playing Christmas music it
kind of makes me wonder if that needed
to happen before the evil gingerbread
man could attack considering how many
characters in trick-or treat become
vulnerable the moment that they ruined a
Halloween tradition it could be that the
warm fire and Christmas music were the
things protecting the family until they
both went out it brings to mind Macy who
became the target of a horde of dead
school children the moment that she
extinguished the final Jackal Lantern
Beth was punished for choosing boyfriend
over family and leaving them and now hoe
junr happened to be the closest victim
when when the flame and music went out
or maybe it has something to do with him
trying to take a bite out of the
gingerbread man like you're not supposed
to eat the cookies you're supposed to
leave them out for Santa but a be fair
that gingerbread man was kind of begging
to be eaten the family is unable to save
hoe Jr practically burning the house
down in the process as the clock rolls
over to December 24th Christmas Eve Omi
explains to Maxx's cousin Stevie and
Jordan that Kampus judges them not just
on their behavior but also by what they
believe in their hearts as the two of
them head to the upstairs bathroom
they're attacked by the contents of the
unmarked packages that Kus left for them
the previous day Jordan is devoured by
Durk clown who seems to have grown
larger since abducting Beth but the
adults are able to save Stevie and fend
it off only to come face to unsettling
face with
[Music]
perta the adults in the Attic not only
have to pry Pera from off of Sarah but
they're charged by Teddy cloud and
continually jabbed by the robot Tick
Tock that still sounds weird every time
I say it now downstairs the gingerbread
Trio stages an attack on Howard who is
able to fend them off with the help of
his dog but when the family reconvenes
in the living room something can be
heard skullking above the
seal dur clown falls through from above
in another massive battle with the army
of toys ensues but before Aunt Dorothy
can fire off the finishing shot the
family finds out just what was hiding in
those creepy snowmen that have been
piling up outside the
house these are the U Lads that I
mentioned earlier once they break
through the wall it's pretty much game
over one of them steals the baby then
Aunt Dorothy and Uncle Howard are yanked
out of the house via chain not long
after realizing that they'll have to
ditch the house in order to have any
chance to survive they make a break for
the broken down snowplow out in the
street but Omi stays back to finish what
she started with Kampus all of those
years ago everyone knows that Old St
Nick comes down the chimney to give that
is give presents to children so you'd
expect that his opposite half would come
down the chimney and take and that's
exactly what he does take the life of
the girl who it had given a warning to
so many decades before who needs Santa
Claus when this fabled bringer of fear
possesses a huge pair of actual claws to
open up his Satchel of tricks and let
the Evil toys within pounce on the old
woman outside Max watches as his family
is picked off one by one by the snow
beast burrowing around under the icy
powder proving that it would have been
impossible to escape at any point only
he and Stevie make it to the snowplow
and when the elves abduct her he finally
finds himself face to face with Kus an
interesting detail here is that when he
finally gets a good look at the creature
that's been haunting his family it
doesn't seem to present its true phase
it's almost as if it's wearing the skin
of an old man resembling something a
little bit closer to the traditional
Santa Claus director Michael dhy may
have indirectly addressed this in a 2022
interview with slashfilm we wanted to go
with something that looked ancient you
know something that looked like it
walked out of the Dark Ages in a sense
the fur pelts the heavy coats the rusty
chains but we also wanted to acknowledge
that everybody's interpretation of kmus
is different so we like the idea that we
never fully reveal kmus you see a face
but is that his face or not Kampus gives
Max his ripped up letter back making it
clear that it was his wish that
triggered all of this he realizes he is
now the one being Left Alive to tell the
tale to a new generation Max receives
the same Bell that was once given to Omi
to remind her not to take the holiday
for granted but before the slay and the
horrible creatures that came on it take
off into the night Max comes upon it and
sees one more frightful Twist on the
Christmas stories that he's accustomed
to most cliche Christmas movies have a
scene where someone hears Santa Claus
landing on the roof with his reindeer
but those do not sound like reindeer
Kampus as usual has his own Twisted
variant known as Yul goats like many of
the creatures that assist him during the
Christmas season UL goats have ties to
ancient Pagan religion Thor the Norse
god of thunder was said to have a
chariot pulled by these magic goats but
just like with Kampus the Christian
Church feared these creatures and
declared them as demonic Tales were
spread of the Demonic U goats roaming
Scandinavia for food and scaring
children like some of the others the Yu
goat is still a part of some Nordic
Christmas celebrations today most
notably in Sweden in the form of a giant
decorative goat made of straw that
pranksters like to try to burn down
every year the UL goats pulling
krampus's slay are huge aggressive
monsters with black fur ram likee horns
and an intimidating Roar by the way
listen to the music being played by the
uads right here as they prepare to take
[Music]
off it sounds a lot like the traditional
Krampus L music that I played
[Music]
earlier that's a very cool detail that I
never would have noticed had I not made
this video max finds the elves
restraining his cousin Stevie and in the
last push of desperation tries taking
back his wish and asking that he be
taken instead of his family he throws
the Kampus Bell and in the spot it
landed in the ground cracks and opens up
a huge fissure leading straight to hell
it seems that he's finally going to make
good on the old stories of the half goat
half demon that drags misbehaving kids
to an appointment with Satan himself
when Max realizes that Stevie is going
to be thrown into the pit for his own
transgression he begs The malefic Entity
to please take him instead after
touching a cold claw to the child's
tears it seems that maybe Max has
learned his lesson and the horn
hellbringer may actually back down but
then this
happens the child's misery is amusing to
that there is no Redemption when it
comes to Christmas wishes as it turns
out Stevie is hurled into the pit and
Max follows not long after but somehow
Max wakes up the next day Christmas
morning almost as if the horror of the
last 2 days was only a dream he comes
downstairs for presents with his family
who are all alive but something seem
seems off and Max realizes it when he
opens one present containing the Kampus
Bell causing everyone to realize that
the nightmare that they thought they had
awoken from was reality a glance out the
window reveals the truth they've been
captured inside one of the creatures
many snow globes in a room filled with
the many families that he's punished
over thousands of years the message when
it comes to clus is a simple one you
better watch out because ending up on
the naughty list is easier than you
might think and the consequences are
much worse than you'd expect an eternity
of suffering and a personal hell stuck
inside a house with family members you
can stand to spend 3 days with every
year like Sam Kampus is not necessarily
a villain but rather an enforcer of
holiday tradition if you don't break the
rules he won't be a problem for you
except for the delivery driver that guy
was just unlucky and now that I think
about it the baby what could the baby
have done to deserve eternity in hell
and why wasn't the delivery driver there
with them in the snow globe so many
questions over the years we've seen Kus
adapt with the time surviving religious
bands and merging with other holidays to
stay relevant through postcards
storytelling traditional parades and
festivals and now movies Kus seems to be
more popular than ever thanks to a boom
of kampo movies in the 2010s including
rare exports kampo the Christmas devil
kampo the Reckoning Kampus Unleashed
Kampus the devil returns mother Kampus
and maybe the king of them all Kampus
and also my video on Kampus which you
just watch to get the full picture
though you have to also see my video on
Sam from trick-or-treat you'll find that
video on the left remember to subscribe
to cz's world for new Horrors every week
ring the sleigh bell for all
notifications and I will see you in the
next one assuming we both
[Music]
survive